support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy okay this video is going to be on
significant figures and uncertainty at
least an introduction to both so what is
uncertainty and what does it refer to in
making measurements simply refers to the
idea that we can't always make an exact
measurements when we're measuring things
we are limited by our devices that we
use to take the measurements and we're
also limited by our senses right like we
use our eyes and our ears and our our
noses right to to to sort of cage what
what it is we're measuring so we're
limited in our ability to make an exact
measurement okay so the idea of some
skills are accurate within you know
within a panel plus or minus 1 pound on
a scale so let's say a man's truly is
180 185 pounds the scale might read 180
for my everyone in 86 it might wait it
might read 185 the the idea here though
is that we are uncertain we are
uncertain about that last digit whether
it's going to be a four a five or a six
okay we have another we can have another
example in which we have a skill that's
accurate 2.0 one pound right so the man
my way 185 point zero three pounds and
the scale would read with the ending
ending in point zero two point zero
three or point zero four and in this
case we have a higher level of certainty
because we have more digits okay and
both of these examples are mentioned
here the rightmost digit the rightmost
digit was was the one that we were
uncertain about right that's the one
we're estimating
in both of these examples we have what's
called significant figures significant
figures which are the digits in the
number that that have meaning and
contribute to the level of certainty
okay so how do you know which digits are
significant well you'd seek out the
significant figure rules or sig fig
rules I'll probably just a sig figs
henceforth so which digits are
significant first rule all nonzero
digits which includes 1 through 9 are
significant always so in the first
example we had 185 184 186 all those
digits there are nonzero digits so they
are all significant so in those in those
three numbers we have three significant
figures three sig figs rule number two
all zeroes written between nonzero
digits are significant so you'll notice
in the second example we had 180 5.03
102 and point zero for the zero here is
in between these other nonzero digits
and nonzero digits are always
significant so in this case we've got
five significant figures in each of
those three different examples example
numbers third rule
okay all zeros written after nonzero
digits and and this is in all caps here
by simultaneously at and after or to the
right of the decimal point are
significant so the zero has to be after
a non-zero digit and after the decimal
point and it would be significant ok I
will cover an example of that in just a
moment rule number four all zeros to the
left of a decimal but to the right of a
non-zero digit are significant ok we'll
also cover that and rule number five all
leading zeros are not significant ok so
let's go through some examples here and
give the number of significant figures
according to these rules ok so we got
0.005 two grams ok well I know according
to rule number one that five and two are
definitely significant because they are
nonzero digits but what about these
zeros well are they written between
nonzero digits nope they're they're
leading right are they written after
nonzero digits know so rule two and
three are not going to apply all 0 is
the left of a decimal ok this one but
right of a non-zero digit or significant
OTT these zeroes here are to the left of
the streaming this first 0 is to the
left of the decimal place but it's not
to the right of a non-zero digit so rule
number four doesn't apply number 5 says
all leading zeros are not saving
significant so these first three zeros
are not significant digits so here we
have two sig figs or to SF and that
should make sense because these zeros
don't really carry any meaning the
values that are actually of you know
that actually means something are the 52
in these in these decimal places here
right the the number doesn't it's not an
actual bits on a value until we reach
those numbers right it doesn't really
say anything ok be 504
nonzero digits there are definitely
significant zero is written between
nonzero digits are significant so that's
definitely significant there are three
sig figs here so and I'll put to the
side here that for the first one we use
rule number one as well as rule number
five and for the second one where you
use rule number one as well as whatever
to okay number or letter c six seven
eight seven that one's easy all of them
are nonzero digits that's four
significant figures so that one was only
rule number one d 6.00 six definitely a
sig fig okay now zero is between nonzero
digits these zeros are not between
nonzero digits they're only to the right
okay so rule number two doesn't apply
all zero is written after nonzero digits
and after decimal points so these zeros
here are after the six and
simultaneously after the decimal point
so they are carrying meaning and they
are significant so that's three
significant figures so that's rules one
and three okay 60 or sumi-e 60.00
kilometers that's pretty much the same
thing as SD right we've got the the
number the six is definitely significant
the zeros that are written after nonzero
digits and to the right of the decimal
point that's these two right those are
significant and then all zeros to the
left of the decimal but right of a
non-zero digit are significant so this
zero here is to the left of the decimal
point but to the right of the non-zero
digit so that one's significant as well
so that's four significant figures and
if you ever have a significant figure to
the left and a significant figure to the
right all the numbers all the digits in
between those two two significant
figures are going to be significant okay
so for this one we had rules 1 3 & 4
okay and f 0.08 40 okay so leading zeros
not significant 84 does it have to be
significant and then the zero is after a
non-zero digit and to the right of the
decimal point so that one significant so
that is three significant figures so
that one is rules 15 and 3 or 1 35
however you want to look at it hope that
video was helpful in introducing
significant figures and uncertainty I
have some more things on significant
figures as far as the rules when it
comes to arithmetic and rounding as well
as the idea of exact measurements hope
that we do is helpful thanks for
watching if you found that video helpful
be sure to figure with the like and
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already also be sure to share the video
with anyone you think might find it
helpful thanks and happy studying